[Musique]
oui
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode du vip l'émission qui met en
lumière des personnalités yvelinoise de
tout horizon cette semaine on va se
retrouver avec stanislas coupé au genre
stanislas alors je vais commencer par
présenter tu as 12 ans tu en cinquième
je viens de rambouillet donc dans les
yvelines et tu es déjà un vrai vidéaste
donc tu as deux chaînes youtube sur
l'histoire et dont une où tu postent des
vidéos toutes les semaines sur un sujet
différent par exemple les personnalités
publiques
les événements ou bien son corps sur une
ville donc c'est une réelle passion pour
toi l'histoire oui j'adore l'histoire
cette passion vient depuis l'âge de 5
ans j'ai découvert l'histoire en lisant
des livres sur le sujet j'ai aussi
découvert l'émission secrets d'histoire
présenté par stéphane bern qui est
vraiment génial et ça m'a donné envie de
vulgariser l'histoire en faisant des
petites vidéos toute simple toute bête
que je publie chaque semaine sur youtube
et qui permettent aux gens de découvrir
l'histoire tout simplement comme le
titre de la chaîne youtube et oui c'est
vrai que du coup tu t'arrêtes pas là
parce qu'en fait tu veux partager cette
passion avec les autres en fait donc on
va commencer un peu par le début si tu
veux bien du coup instruire faire tes
propres vidéos ça a commencé très tôt
chez toi bon t'as que 12 ans mais ça a
commencé bien plus tôt justement on va
regarder un petit extrait d'une de ses
premières vidéos si tu veux bien oui
aujourd'hui je vais vous faire découvrir
l'incroyable destin de louis dieudonné
plus connu sous le nom de louis xiv
[Musique]
oui dieudonné n'est en 1638 au château
neuf de saint germain en laye
il prend le pouvoir à la mort de son
père en 1643 est alors 5 ans
morte avait seulement dix ans quant à
fait cette vidéo là c'était phoques
alors comment tu prenais pour tourner
ses premières vidéos qui était un peu
sur le modèle de secrets d'histoire en
fait pendant le premier confinement pour
pas m'ennuyer parce que du coup on était
bloqué à la maison
j'ai voulu donc je fais du projet pic et
le matériel de mon père avec la caméra
tous les deux jours à peu près j'allais
dans le jardin alors j'avais écrit des
petits scénarios sur les personnages de
l'histoire j'ai les noms gerlain je me
filmer avec mon texte puis après je
faisais le montage est en vous le
présenter ça mon père on voit
l'évolution la première je suis assis
sur un tabouret devant ma maison est la
dernière je suis sur un fond vert
parlant de léonard de vinci donc on voit
qu'il ya une évolution une évolution
mais j'ai vraiment fait ça pour m'amuser
me divertir pendant le confinement mais
comment ta femme n'a réagi contador soit
parce qu'elles sont elles deux elles
devaient pouvoir prendre le matériel
tourné dans le jardin comme ça bah au
départ mon père était un peu incrédule
et comprenait pas ce que je faisais
j'allais tous les jours dans le jardin
aulas hockey est à la fois je vais
montrer on en a fait un souhait avec
microsoft soit on s'est vraiment amusé à
faire ça mais du coup comment tu
trouvais ce sujet alors généralement
j'allais voir les vidéos de secrets
d'histoire les émissions d'après comme
j'étais bien dans le sujet j'écrivais le
scénario en mai dans un peu de
recherches internet ou dans des livres
et puis après je faisais la vidéo est
dans le jardin avec les montages et tout
ça est arrivé très vite affaire s'est
vidé la passe quand même filmé et monté
parler comme ça mais en fait mon père
fait des vidéos pour son travail donc il
a un petit logiciel qui s'appelle cap
tasiast très efficace et j'ai eu envie
d'apprendre un peu à l'utiliser alors
mon père mais expliquez tout ça et j'ai
découvert petit à petit et comme j'étais
passionné d'histoire et de vidéos ça m'a
donné envie de transmettre ma passion
en vulgarisant l'histoire à travers les
vidéos d'ailleurs à pas par rapport à ça
tu as créé une chaîne youtube aussi à
ces jeunes qui s'appelait rené pleymo
c'est une chaîne dont que tu met en
scène des playmobil un peu pour
expliquer l'histoire pour l'histoire
comme tu dis a commencé t'es venue cette
idée de créer cette chaîne là bas en
fait quand j'étais petit comme tous les
enfants j'ai joué au playmobil j'adorais
ça les jouets tout ça alors je me suis
dit j'aimerais alliés les playmobil avec
la vidéo et l'histoire
alors du coup un jour j'ai écrit cinq
scénarios sur les cinq périodes de
l'histoire que j'aurais aimé traités et
je suis allé voir mon père je les dis
voilà j'ai écrit cinq scénarios est ce
qu'on pourrait ce que tu pourrais
valider le scénario ce qu'on pourrait
faire les vidéos alors on a relu on a
corrigé et on s'est lancé dedans alors
c'était compliqué parce qu'il fallait
prendre les les photos des personnages
après fallait les détours et sur
internet avec pour avoir de la
transparence fallait incrusté les fonds
fallait pourrait enregistrer les voix
donc c'est c'était assez long mais on
s'en est bien sorti alors at dans la
première vidéo ont cherché le style 1
c'était ont balbutié un peu puis après
petit à petit ou s'est amélioré et là il
en reste encore deux affaires sur
l'ancien régime et sur le premier
remplir avec napoléon donc on espère
pouvoir les faire un jour c'est pourquoi
utiliser le playmobil du coup ça parce
que en fait t'es vraiment déjoué que
j'adorais en plus appelés les enfants ça
les touche ça ils aiment beaucoup les
plus mobiles et ça leur permet de
découvrir l'histoire à travers est joué
alors ça m'a vraiment donné envie de le
faire et ça prend du temps par exemple
de points pour une vidéo de type combien
de temps ça prend pour pour cette chaîne
la poussette chaîne l'a
beaucoup de temps parce qu'il faut comme
j'ai dit il ya plein d'étapes je serai
pas dire exactement mais il ya beaucoup
de temps pour le faire c'est très long
c'est pour ça justement que j'ai eu
l'idée de créer l'histoire tout
simplement je voulais je voulais publier
des vidéos plus souvent des vidéos tout
simple de toute bête que je fais
rapidement alors ça mais j'ai eu l'idée
pendant les vacances de juillet la les
dernières vacances d'été j'ai eu l'idée
de créer cette chaîne pour pour mettre
en pla mettre en scène les personnages
de l'histoire où les différentes
périodes de l'histoire des vidéos tout
simple je publie chaque semaine et qui
permettent aux gens de découvrir
l'histoire tout simplement mais
justement on va parler d'un peu cette
chaîne qu'un format complètement
différente du groupe parce que tu te
mets en scène cette fois on te voir et
ça s'appelle donc l'histoire tout
simplement que tu tient actuellement à
tu fais une vidéo par semaine c'est ça
c'est ça tous les lundis voilà tous les
lundis et à ce que tu peux nous
expliquer un peu ce que tu fais sur
cette chaîne du début à la fin on va
alors sur l'a7 chaîne j'explique
l'histoire ont de grands personnages
historiques ou de périodes de l'histoire
donc je fais les vidéos chaque semaine
tous le samedi je me prend du temps pour
faire le tournage et le montage je
publie chaque lundi alors je fais un
live à 8h30
et ça me permet chaque semaine de faire
découvrir aux gens nouvelle période où
un nouveau personnage ou une nouvelle
vie ce que j'ai fait des vidéos sur
ville d'eau sur la ville de cambrai ou
des passions comme les reconstitueurs
historique et du coup on va regarder un
petit extrait de ta g t au sur cambrai
d'accord
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode de l'histoire tout
simplement avec cette semaine un format
un peu particulier puisque je vais vous
faire visiter une ville mais ce n'est
pas n'importe quelle ville faire il
s'agit de cambrai la ville d'où est
originaire toute la famille de mon père
comment est une ville d'environ 33 mille
habitants située dans la région des
hauts de france bref vous l'avez compris
cambrai
[Musique]
dans le nord certains parlent encore le
pack quoi fameux ch'timi que dany l'a
rendu célèbre dans ses caisses et le
ch'timi ça donne ça
cfcm
métier quand il annonce est pas moins
forte qu'en même temps je t'appelle
qu'au creusot jus dans le garage et
torturé des trucs pour le tiers des
fruits dès ce midi cocktail raccords et
du coup on voit bien la différence avec
la première vidéo d'ailleurs quand tu
vois ça le résultat final par rapport à
tes premières vidéos par exemple à ce
que ça te est ce que tu t'es content du
travail fini ce que ça te rend un peu un
peu fier quand même je suis quand même
content parce que les premières vidéos
ou carrément une évolution les premières
vidéos y avait j'avais pas une bonne
lumière j'avais un mensonge utilisé
palémon musique j'étais vraiment content
pouvoir faire qu'en grèce a donné un
nouvel horizon en fait un nouvel horizon
à mes vidéos d'autres découvertes pour
mes spectateurs et du coup j'ai beaucoup
aimé faire ça j'ai visité des lieux
j'interviewais des personnes des musées
et tout ça j'étais vraiment content de
le faire et oui j'étais fier j'étais
faire du résultat final beaucoup
travailler quand même ah oui surcroît on
a beaucoup travaillé le tournage c'était
le plus dur on a passé deux jours
non-stop presque de tournage à la base
on pensait le faire en un jour donc on
sait on s'est vite rendu compte que
c'était pas possible
donc mon père s'était calée un jour de
congé pour qu'on puisse le faire
et après youtube c'est le montage il
fallait reconvertir les fichiers vidéo
en déchets facilement travaillable au
montage parce que à la base c'était trop
lourd le logiciel aurait pas aimé alors
il fallait convertir les fichiers
prennent tout montage fallait faire
valider par mon père parce que on
pourrait y avoir des problèmes de
montage pas encore promo dire je suis
pas encore très bon pour ça et beaucoup
ça a été ça a été très très long et très
très dur mais je suis vraiment content à
du résultat final et comment tu t'y
prends du coup c'est toi qui fait tout
du début à la fin donc par rapport aux
recherches jusqu'au montage ça dépend
quelle vidéo olivier aux normales je
dirais comme ma dernière vidéo sur
joséphine de beauharnais je les fais
tout seul l'écriture de scénario juste
je fais valider le scénario et le
montage par mon père
après il ya le tournage que je fais tout
seul avec avec mon ordinateur
il ya le montage que je fais tout seul
aussi je vais chercher des illustrations
des images pour illustrer mes propos je
vais les incruster dans monde en montage
jeu mais je mets des noms si on
n'intervient des personnes évidemment
pour cambrai est là c'était c'était
différent on a utilisé
qu'est ce que tu fous
pour caen brest est différent parce que
là je me suis je me suis fait filmer par
mon père je pourrais pas d'ambition on a
fait longtemps un peu tous les deux
aussi voir ce que c'était très compliqué
donc évidemment cambrai c'était plus dur
que les autres vidéos
mais sinon voila je suis content de tout
ce que j'ai fait alors on m'a dit que tu
avais un idole stéphane bern fait ça et
là il me connaît tous évidemment alors
on m'a dit que tu allais le rencontrer
oui c'est vrai je vais le rencontrer
dans une semaine je suis vraiment
content alors déjà pour ça j'ai deux
personnes à remercier déjà lui-même
parce qu'il m'a permis il m'a proposé de
rencontrer donc je le remercie beaucoup
et aussi diane béthune qui est
journaliste à la voix du nord qui a fait
un article dans le journal intitulé fan
de stéphane stanislas racontera en bray
et du coup samassa m'appelle ça a permis
à stéphane bern devoir de voir cet
article est de me proposer de le
rencontrer du coup je le remercie
beaucoup ça m'a vraiment permis de
réaliser mon rêve en fait c'est mon rêve
qui se réalise depuis tout petit depuis
que j'ai découvert secrets d'histoire
mais qu'est ce que tu as me devançaient
gto justement tu aimerais reproduire toi
alors ce que j'aime beaucoup dans
secrets d'histoire déjà c'est le style
de stéphane bern et l'instit très
décontracté et secrets d'histoire c'est
hyper agréable à regarder franchement
avec les historiens qui parle il parle
très bien stéphane bern présente les
lieux et conique des vies des
personnages jeu ça raconte la vie de
tous les grands personnages ou soit
napoléon même quelques fautes des
personnes que je connaissais même pas
j'ai découvert toussaint louverture
c'est ça qui m'a permis de faire la
vidéo que j'ai publié sur ma chaîne donc
vraiment merci merci stéphane bern et
merci ce qu'est l'histoire c'est
vraiment génial quitte à donner refuge
du coup de faire à peu près le même type
de vidéo on va dire mais du coup toi
qu'est ce que tu veux dans lé tournage
qu'est ce que tu préfères on quand je
suis chez cgt aulas
déjà j'ai beaucoup de montage le montage
c'est vraiment un mondial a entre
guillemets j'aime beaucoup faire le
montage et le tournage aussi j'aime
beaucoup par exemple quand on a des
quand j'ai des copains qui viennent chez
moi on me fait souvent des vidéos on
adore ça et j'aime beaucoup le tournage
aussi ça permet de de s'exprimer un peu
de ça reflète nos sentiments entre
guillemets
c'est exactement ça et tu as des
difficultés des fois parce que tu es là
tu te dis que tu as menée en beaucoup de
choses près ce que défend d'être chose
que tu trouves duroux ou voir même
parfois des gens qui se disent pour ça
c'est un enfant si le perçoivent bien
bas franchement ça va quand on est allé
interviewer des gens pour cambrai
notamment on a toujours eu un très bon
accueil les gens étaient très
sympathiques donc pour l'instant j'ai
jamais vraiment rencontré ce genre de
problème ça va être tant donné je suis
un enfant chez des vidéos ça donnait
envie
donc vous pour l'instant j'ai jamais
rencontré ce genre de problème peut-être
que ça arrivera un jour où c'est
possible et ça va le sport pas et donc
est ce que tu aimerais faire pour tâche
est plus tard alors j'ai pas j'ai
plusieurs projets en tête déjà j'ai les
petits scénarios de vidéos normale en
cours aussi j'aimerais à faire des
j'aimerais visiter des châteaux avec
avec leurs propriétaires montrer
l'arrière du décor ce que les gens ne
voient pas un peu comme stéphane bern à
bientôt
et aussi j'aimerais utilité je peux
j'aimerais pouvoir boire drone un drone
pour faire des images aériennes par
exemple des châteaux on a par exemple un
objectif visiter un château qui est pas
loin de cambrai qui a plus de 10 kg et
dans l'europe qui est dans la même
famille depuis plus de mille ans donc ça
fait beaucoup on aimerait bien visiter
avec ses propriétaires avec des vues
aériennes et un drone ce serait pas mal
sans vos projets en tout cas et on
espère que ça marchera du coup on comme
quoi il n'y a pas d'âge pour apprendre
l'histoire aux autres elle a besoin on
peut très bien apprendre à tout public
et donc c'est la fin de ce ver
grecque-melkite était consacré n'hésitez
pas à aller sur la chaîne donc
l'histoire tout simplement pour en
apprendre un peu plus sur l'histoire
avec stanislas en tout cas nous on va
continuer à tuer on espère que ça marche
quant à nous on se retrouve très vite
merci d'avoir suivi ce v y paie
[Musique]
mais